so jordan first of all congratulations
on the filament man thank you carlos i
appreciate it
you know it feels like it's a golden age
for dancing right now you know with
everybody doing tick tock videos
and a lot of dancers being featured on
shows like ellen and all that how do you
feel
you know you growing up being a dancer
being accomplished a dancer yourself
i i appreciate that um i'm happy i'm
happy
any any time that there is a and you
know an arc in social culture
where art is
influencing art is inspiring art is
what you see and how you navigate life
um you know the fact that like tic toc
for example i mean it's inspired so
many especially the younger generation
to tackle things that
you know i didn't see a lot of as a kid
you know i didn't i i didn't i didn't
grow up with social media like that
wasn't a thing that i had when i was in
school and so
you know to have a platform like that uh
where you are encouraged and
and and inspired to try something new
and
and be artistic and you know spread your
wings in that way is a really
exciting thing and and i think that for
me personally growing up that was dance
films that was
you know um you know any musical
films anything that that i could get my
hands on to get my eyes and ears on
that made me feel really good first of
all as
an audience member and be as an artist
and as a creative myself
inspired me to do something you know
it's like step up and and and you got
served
and honey and say the last dance etc etc
that you know
made me feel a certain way and inspired
me to do something and and
now that's that's on everyone sets like
on a device that's in everyone's pocket
now
you know yeah that's amazing and you
know in this film
it's great because you get to work with
so many pros
so many like so just it just must be
great to work with people that
know exactly what they're doing what was
it like working with sabrina i mean
she's so talented in so many ways plus
she's an exec on this
which must have been very cool oh and
it's a blast i mean she i i adore her to
death you know i've known her for a very
long time and
and um you know she i've just been so
proud of how she's navigated
uh her her life and her career it's been
really
exciting especially as a friend to watch
happen
um yeah that's really great i mean i've
been at this for i've been doing this
for 16 years
and and have been very fortunate to you
know
have my hands on a lot of different
things and develop and create a you know
a bunch of different things and to
you know be a part of something like
this that i think is going to be very
culturally influential
uh again especially you know the younger
generations it's
uh it's exciting to see and especially
seeing sabrina
lead it in such a beautiful way is i'm
proud and proud of her
yeah now you have a big day coming up it
was supposed to be this month your big
wedding day being pushed back to
back to november do you what are your
plans are you still gonna still think
you're gonna head out maybe go to hawaii
what's that yeah that's that's
that's the plan you know we're taking it
step by step you know
like i said earlier left there's your
curveballs and you know how you
navigated is
is entirely up to you and we you know
we're we're good
we're doing life together still you know
we're we
we love each other and we live in the
same house and we're we're doing the
thing and we're navigating you know all
the covet nonsense and
um you know if if if we are able yeah
we're definitely gonna
head out to hawaii in november and do
the thing and if not then we'll
you know get married in my backyard and
it'll it'll be great we'll celebrate it
another time
that's awesome and finally if you are
going to put together a dance team
of people that you've worked with that
you need to be on your dance team of
like
four people people that i've worked with
um ben vereen
um i'm gonna throw him up there for sure
uh lindsey arnold who was my partner in
dates with the stars
i'll get her on there um
man
why is it koshi she's a she's a freaking
she's a
she's a force i'll get her on the team
as well and do that
um yeah and you said four people
yeah it's hard to pick with all that
talent man
yeah it is it is it definitely is um
man geez well listen if you need a
fourth
i'm right here there we go
there you go how about that carlos
bustaman okay
all right man hey great talking to you
thank you guys take care
you